wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7 Uhr unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
rosto darunter auch der Flughafen daher
die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte arbeitet
wie gewohnt die jeder Offizier ist am
Arbeitsplatz und wir stören die Arbeit
der Stadt nicht und als
als wir hierher gekommen sind sie
mussten wir feststellen er
norbertäteritorien sind verloren worden
enorm
Menschenmassen sind verloren worden um
mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die sanitätsverluster pro
Tag machen manchmal bis 1000 Menschen
aus das sind die getöteten die
Verwundeten und die Verweigerer es
mangelt an Munition und es mangelt an
der Leitung die Menschen sind in der
gastgasse der Chef ist Stabs ist
geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat dass
wir uns dem Gebäude nähern